I'm getting super evil vibes here I can
change my form to something else if this
makes you uncomfortable
hey guys they'll go back
don't worry is much more palatable
congratulations are you so excited to be
here like a movie honey there's a giant
Lego I'm super excited about this to be
a part of this franchise such an honor
and you know I've been playing with
LEGOs all my life even as a grown woman
I like to build put things together
dream big you know and get thing on
Legos I know I hasn't been stepping on
any Lego since I clean up after myself
it's called being responsible girl strip
girl's trip - what's going on girl strip
till we try to make it happen I'm
praying it happens before the end of the
year and it comes I'll make sure that's
my goal that's what I see in my mind
have you received a script no I haven't
haven't received a script how to receive
the contract you know just me and the
girls talking to each other we probably
just gonna film it ourselves on our cell
phone
[Music]